- Well, welcome to AWS re:Invent, day one.
Very excited to be here with all of you.
Today, our topic revolves around
cloud resiliency with
shared responsibility.
All of you have data that you care for
within your enterprises.
And ensuring that that data is resilient
is critical to being
prepared for disasters,
cyber attacks, and even accidental,
non-intentional malicious attacks
that might even happen
from your end users.
My name is Teresa Miller.
I'm the Senior Director of
Technical Marketing at Cohesity.
And I'm joined by my
very special guest here,
Kevin, who is one of our customers.
Can you introduce yourself?
- Yes, ma'am.
Hey, everyone, I'm Kevin Lomax.
I'm the IT Director at Pearl
River Community College.
I've been there for six years.
Prior to that, I was in the
United States Army for 20 years
where I retired and took on a job
at the University of Southern Mississippi.
And then my path has led me to
Pearl River Community College
and I've enjoyed every second
there over the last six years.
And welcome to the session.
- So excited to have you here.
Let's go ahead and break
down the agenda though.
We'll get a lot of time with Kevin though,
thankfully, appreciate your time.
- Absolutely.
- So our session today, we'll be together
for probably the next
45 minutes to an hour
and it's broken into four sections.
So we're gonna start out
by talking about some of the challenges
that come from using just
native backup options
that come like with AWS, for example.
But also we're gonna look
at the industry perspective
on this and what our
customers are telling us
they're being faced with that require them
to dive a little bit further
into shared responsibility
amongst other things.
From there, we're gonna sit down
for probably a good 20 to 30 minutes
and we're gonna hear firsthand
what's keeping you up at night
and how you're solving
some of those problems
so that you can all learn from
Kevin and his experiences.
And then we'll spend the
last 12 minutes or so today
on these last two points.
We'll talk about how you
can improve your resilience
with Cohesity and I'm
gonna show you a demo
of a solution that we call Cloud Vaulting
that can really help with ensuring
you have the right protection in place.
So with that, there's a
couple different things.
Let's start with those challenges.
So many of you are likely using AWS
or you're here doing some discovery
around which next
workload you might deploy
or even just getting started.
So when it comes to backing
up your AWS workloads,
you get native protection capabilities
that oftentimes are
coming with your tenant.
But, and I want you to
use those by the way,
but they're only gonna get you so far.
So as we talk about things today,
I want you to try to
find those limitations
and how much more you
could be doing beyond that
with a third party solution.
The other thing that I
think is really important
revolves around security
considerations, data sovereignty.
So if you're using those
native options from AWS,
they're also gonna be protected on AWS.
And so you may have
requirements that lead you
to using different media, different clouds
to ensure that you're
following your guidance
that your enterprise needs
and you're also like
GDPR or SOX, et cetera.
From an industry perspective,
when it comes to the enterprise
and industry challenges,
shared responsibility is key.
I recently had the opportunity
to interview somebody from AWS.
And I think one of the things
that stuck with me the most
during that conversation is so simple,
but I think it's so important
is that even if your
data's in their cloud,
you are responsible for
protecting your data.
So you're responsible
for the credentialing
and securing and preventing folks
or malicious attackers
from getting at your data.
And you are also responsible
for recovering it.
So we'll unpack that more today.
Many of you in terms of
outgrowing your solutions,
you may have something else.
You're gonna find that
because for example,
let's take a cyber attack.
Cyber attacks have so many
different unknowns to them.
You have no way of knowing
how that's going to unfold.
Something extremely basic
is not gonna get you to,
for example, clean room recovery
or being able to do forensic analysis
or allowing for the right
levels of replication.
So you may outgrow it for
a wide variety of reasons.
Some of those could be the case.
Cloud costs, we all wanna
keep that pocketbook at bay.
We don't wanna over budget or over commit.
So having a strategy
for this will also help.
And then the last piece I wanna call out
is the compliance and data sovereignty.
I know I personally previously had worked
at a company that was global.
So a lot of the cloud
housing was happening
between the United States and Europe.
And we really had to be careful
about how we were managing that data,
preventing the wrong eyes from seeing it.
Even if it was within the company,
we had to keep it segregated.
All right, so now that we've talked about
some of the industry challenges,
again, these are things our customers
are telling us as well.
We're gonna sit down with
Kevin and hear firsthand
what's top of mind for you.
- [Kevin] Absolutely.
- So to get things started,
let's just talk a little bit
more about your background
a little bit deeper and tell
us what your company is doing.
- So in the state of Mississippi,
where I work at Pearl
River Community College,
I'm on the cybersecurity
initiative for the state.
And the trends that we see
are obviously every day,
these ransomware guys are getting smarter,
they're getting bigger,
they're getting better.
And they're just utilizing
the weaknesses that we have.
So my background is
obviously cybersecurity
and working through the
security parameters,
just kind of understanding more of that
and how we can push to, like
you said, harden our postures.
And even though the data is in the cloud,
we have to make sure that
we continue to secure that.
- Yeah.
I think it's interesting you said
how they're trying to leverage
the weaknesses you have.
So I think it's a good
thing to have that knowing
like you're trying to harden,
but we can't always stay on
the other side of that, right?
So it's an ongoing thing
as what that implied to me.
- Oh, it is.
And they're using better,
we've talked about this before as well,
they've used different parameters now,
they're leveraging social media.
They know how to headline
emails, QR coding,
things like that to get to
reach out to the customer
or to the end users to
know how to grab you
and make you wanna click that link.
And once you click that
link, they've got you.
And then they get in your network
and they just continue to
propagate their way around there.
- Yeah.
And that's not just
desktops, that's servers,
that's cloud infrastructure.
It doesn't matter.
- Every bit of it.
- Yeah.
All right.
So stepping back just a moment,
we'll get into some of
that cyber resilience stuff
a little bit further,
but how long have you
been a Cohesity customer?
And then why did you
choose Cohesity and AWS?
- So Pearl River's been
a Cohesity customer
since July of 2022.
We unfortunately had a cyber event
and we had to step back and figure out
how do we progress from this?
And we did proof of concepts
for many different vendors.
And I think probably about day one,
five hours into our proof of concept,
we realized Cohesity was the
path that we wanted to go.
Just because we had to, after
a cyber event, they just wait.
They wait, see if you're gonna
patch your vulnerabilities
and they'll try to hit you again.
So we had to make sure
the college understood
and knew that we were gonna provide them
some type of solution that we knew
we could get our data
back and it was safe.
Cohesity provides that
immutability, the air gap,
and most importantly,
one of the big things
touching back on your
security, the quorum.
The quorum is such a
huge piece with Cohesity
knowing you have to have
multiple people that sign off
that allow you to be
able to get to your data
and knowing it's safe.
- What about the AWS side of that?
What made you go with AWS?
- So AWS, knowing that their
data centers are worldwide,
knowing Cohesity's leveraging that data,
spreading it across
there, having the backups.
And AWS is one of the leaders
in the market, obviously.
So putting our stuff in AWS
and making sure, once again,
we know we can retrieve it
and back it up and it's secure
was one of the leading forces in that.
- Nice.
I'm gonna just let people
internalize that a little bit
'cause I think there's
more that's gonna come out
when we get into some
of the actual strategy
and some of the infrastructure
as we keep talking.
So let's transition
then to your experience
around some of the challenges
that companies are facing
as it relates to cyber resilience.
I know you touched on it a little bit,
but I think we can go deeper, right?
- So I'm sure like many
other companies, colleges,
businesses, IT departments are small.
So we don't have the
personnel at Pearl River.
We're a one-stop shop.
We cover everything from
networking, wireless, software,
student information, student
information and data.
We have to make sure
that's safe, it's secure,
it's recoverable.
And that's some of the big
pieces to it, end users.
Like I said before, end
users, unfortunately,
are your biggest vulnerability.
And these bad actors, they don't sleep.
They know how to get
into your environment.
They know how to use them end users.
They know how to figure out
ways to leverage certain pieces.
Once they get in, they move back and forth
and they wanna get as much as they can,
as quick as they can, get out of there
and then try and hold you for that ransom.
- You said you went
through a ransomware event,
expanding on the cyber resilience
and being prepared for that.
I'm just curious, how did you know
that your backups were
clean to recover from?
- We didn't.
We didn't know, they
actually got into our backups
and wiped them.
Fortunately, being in
security, we had a known good,
three days, we'd lost three days of data.
We had one on a server
that we just happened
to do snapshots and backups
and we unplugged it from the network.
And it was luck, it was pure luck.
And that's why at that point in time,
we did not have cloud backups.
So we knew that was a huge key
and we do all of our backups now into,
we have on-prem using Data Protect
and then we also back
it up into Fort Knox.
So, and that's the key
is making sure on-prem
is great for rapid recovery,
if there's no anomalies in your
data and you can get to it.
But having that Fort Knox piece,
that's what'll help you sleep at night
because everybody knows you got,
it's not a, I've said
this a million times,
it's not a matter of if
you're gonna get hit,
it's a matter of when.
And the truth behind that is,
can you recover from that?
And that's the key to all of this.
- So what are some ways
you further increased
cyber resilience with
your critical workloads?
- So one of the main takeaways,
we initially did it through Cisco DNA,
Cisco and Cohesity, thank goodness,
are partners, we're a huge Cisco shop.
Cisco has now advanced into Cisco XDR.
And one of the things
that we made sure to do
was integrate that into
our Cohesity platform.
And like I said before,
we're a small IT shop.
So I don't have the personnel to sit there
and monitor all these systems
and all the things that go on every day.
Well, with Cisco XDR, we
integrated with Cohesity.
If it sees any of those anomalies,
any of your data that has
changed any type of patterns,
Cisco XDR instantly hits,
they take a snapshot.
Take a snapshot of your
data, they notify you,
and it gives you a chance
for your forensics teams,
for your cybersecurity
teams to go in there
at that point in time and see what server,
what event may have triggered that,
and give you a much easier chance
to be able to back up from that.
Other things, end user training.
And we'll hit on that a
little bit later as well.
But making sure you
educate your end users.
Be careful when you click those emails
that look like they come
from CEO, CFO, President.
A lot of times we believe
we're a little more important
than we are.
If they really wanted to get ahold of you,
they're gonna come find you.
An email saying you won $100
for a Starbucks gift card,
that's usually not an
email you wanna click on
to try to say, "Hey, my
CIO really remembered
"the things that I did."
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think, do you have a program
that does actual testing as well?
Have you gone that far?
- So we do.
And one thing that, another thing is,
with Cohesity is the rapid recovery.
And we back up 17 terabytes
of data into Fort Knox
through our testing procedures.
We quarterly test.
We have some servers that
are sitting at a warm site.
Fire 'em up, pull all of our data back.
And it has baffled me every single time.
17 terabytes of data completely
recovered in 17 hours.
An hour a terabyte.
I mean, you think, some of
these ransomware attacks,
people are down for
three, six, nine months.
And you're thinking fully
recovered in 17 hours.
So.
- That's impressive.
- It is.
It's very impressive.
- Yeah.
How often do you do testing?
- So we do it quarterly.
And one of the things that
I always stress to my team
is making sure that we're
doing the tabletop exercises.
We're doing the testing.
Making sure that, just like an NFL game,
reading the playbook, we have to know
everyone's on the same page.
Everyone is doing the
same thing every time.
So if that event happens,
we're a well-oiled machine.
And we can go into that DR plan
and start activating things
and making sure the college
understands and knows.
I mean, we as an IT team have a job
to make sure that college
and those students
believe in us, rely on our data,
rely on our recoverability.
And that's why we have to make sure
we have solutions in
place that can do that.
- Yeah.
Knowing what goes into
having that set up quarterly
sounds aggressive.
So I like hearing that it's possible
that our audience can go back and say,
think about what it's gonna
take to get to that point,
regardless of the size
of the organization.
It is, it's so important.
'Cause for whatever reason,
these things always happen
at 3 a.m. on a weekend.
And so if we don't have that tested
and we don't know how long
the business is gonna be down
and how quick we can get it back up,
that could be a big problem.
- It's funny you say that.
I remember our attack like yesterday.
My boss was at a Garth
Brooks concert in Baton Rouge
when it happened on a Saturday night.
So that was definitely a
night I'll always remember,
but hope I never have to encounter again.
- I hope not either.
- But it's also great that you say that.
One thing that we try to preach to others,
in Mississippi, we have
15 community colleges.
Nobody wants to go through this alone.
We try through our testing procedures
and just people knowing
that we went through it
and seeing them go through
these same type of cyber events.
We've brought them in,
showed them our testing,
showed them the Cohesity platform.
And it's been amazing.
We have, out of the 15,
we have six of the
Mississippi community colleges
now operating and using Cohesity
as their backup platform.
- That's awesome.
- So as I've said, it speaks for itself.
- Yeah, very, very awesome.
So what are some of the
outcomes you've achieved
by using our solution?
- So obviously the biggest outcome
is having a very fluid
disaster recovery plan,
knowing that it works,
being able to test it,
utilize it, having the warm
site, just having the end users,
the training that we provide for them.
Also the team, my team being
able to respond much faster.
Like I said before, Cisco XDR is kind of,
as Cisco likes to say, a sock in a box.
Well, we also have our own
third-party SimSoc solution.
And that goes back to
the small IT departments
and not having the number of personnel
to be able to respond to these events
and take care of these events.
Having that SimSoc and
having that SimSolution
identify and recognize and notify,
and then having those
SLAs for that sock team
to call you and let you know
of anything that's critical or high
helps you be able to first identify
and then be able to respond.
And with Cohesity and continuing
to just add different,
purchase different
third-party applications
and different things to
integrate just helps that.
And AI, everybody knows, I'm
sure y'all are gonna hear that
the entire week here with AI,
but AI is becoming a part of
each and every piece of this.
And it's helping to push not only backups,
but everything else, make things smarter
and utilize some of that AI functionality
to help us be able to
push further into it.
- Yeah, I think that's
extremely interesting.
I think the AI piece is,
it's got both sides to it.
I think the attackers are using AI,
but AI also can help us
on the flip side of it
from a research and recovery perspective.
So I think it's interesting
you mentioned that,
and I agree, they're gonna
hear about AI all week.
So what are your cyber
resilience priorities
for the next 12 months?
- The next 12 months is to
obviously not get hit again
or ever, but continue
to harden our backups,
obviously, continue to test them,
end-user training, all the
time doing end-user training,
phishing, simulated phishing attacks,
warm site, going and making sure
our warm site is fully functional.
Obviously, at some point in time,
making it almost a hot site to be able
just to roll everything
quick, fast if we need to.
But that's hard, and you
hit on that earlier too,
is the financial piece of it.
Not a lot of businesses,
especially small colleges,
struggle from the budget piece of that.
So finding that balance,
what your company can afford,
what you're able to be
able to do with this,
and that's why we went with the on-prem
to be able to backup our stuff on-premise,
and snapshots, recover,
anytime you do any updates,
stuff like that, something goes haywire,
you gotta be able to recover quick.
But then also being able to
have that Fort Knox piece
for that peace of mind knowing
if that on-premise backup
solution gets compromised,
that you have that in-the-cloud,
like I said, immutable air gap solution
that you know you can get,
and you know this is a
good, clean, safe backup.
- Yeah.
So that tells me you kind of follow
the three, two, one backup rule.
Does that sound right?
- Absolutely.
- So can we explain that to the audience?
Or I can jump in and explain what it means
if that's helpful.
So meaning that you're always gonna have
three copies of your data, right?
Two different media types,
which I think is what I'm
hearing you doing, right?
One offline, I heard you say air gap.
- That's right.
- And then immutable, that's
the cyber vaulting Fort Knox.
So even with your company size,
you are finding a way to make sure
that you have all of those
different copies available,
for any situation.
And it's not just cyber events.
Like data disasters happen all the time.
It could be a fire, it could
be a snowstorm, a flood,
it doesn't matter.
You would just have to be
ready for those complexities.
Any additional thoughts on that?
- No, you're exactly right.
And at Pearl River Community College,
I mean, it would be great
for us to say that we,
our DR site was four or 500,
maybe a different time zone away.
It's not the budget, small college,
it's not the sad part in
Mississippi, tornadoes.
We're literally 60 miles,
our DR site 60 miles from our main site.
One tornado could wipe
out both facilities.
So that's where the three, two, one,
the biggest piece is the two for us,
knowing we have the on-prem copy
and most importantly, that
copy of our data in the cloud.
- All right, so thank you
for sharing all of that.
- Absolutely.
- I'm gonna go ahead and transition over
to my next section here.
I wanted to talk a little
bit about resilience.
You shared so many powerful
examples, but I have one.
When we go back to shared responsibility,
Kevin, you hit on our employees,
sometimes are an unintentional threat.
I worked in an enterprise, guess what?
3 a.m. call, but before Valentine's day.
So it actually impacted
everyone's Valentine's day
with this event that I'm
gonna tell you about.
Our desktop team had an automation tool.
We think, yeah, automation's great,
but somewhere along the way,
the permissions were a
little bit more free-flowing
than they should have been.
And what happened was that 3 a.m. call
was me responding to logging
into some of my systems.
This in particular was an exchange server,
some Citrix servers, database servers.
I'm on call, I gotta check it all.
And I see a desktop OS being deployed.
And I'm not kidding.
I'm like, wait, am I awake?
Am I really seeing this, what's going on?
So I think sometimes
we'd right away think,
well, that could be a cyber attack.
Someone got our credentials and did it,
but root cause showed
that there was a misstep
in the hardening.
And so we always have to
be looking and watching
to further harden.
Always learn and grow
from your experiences.
Always being willing to
look a little bit deeper
to see what else could be lingering.
So I thought that was a great example
of why hardening matters and
why it's not a one and done.
- That's right.
- So it ruined my Valentine's
Day and many others.
- It goes to show you, they sit
and wait for those holidays.
Those holidays are someone
sitting at a concert.
They know when to strike for sure.
- They do, they do.
All right, so now I wanna talk,
we'll spend probably the
next 12 to 15 minutes
on this last part.
So this is an example of
the flexibility of choice
that Kevin really talked
about a lot today.
So regardless of where your AWS data
or any of your enterprise
data for that matter sits,
so if you look at the location,
you got Edge, Data Center,
Cloud, Sovereign Cloud,
we can help you protect it.
The consumption models are
completely flexible as well,
self-managed, SaaS, partner-managed.
So regardless of the size
of your organization,
small or large, you can
put more of that on us
or you can own that more yourself.
The most important three
takeaways on this slide
are at the bottom.
You get to manage this from a single UI.
You don't have to have a separate product.
Go ahead and still use
your AWS protection,
but we're gonna help you
get a little bit further
and I have some architecture slides
where I can show you how this might apply
to your environment in just a moment,
but also allows you to
kind of mix and match.
You can use any of these things.
You can protect any of these workloads
and I'll also give you the opportunity
to see that in just a second.
If you are an AWS customer
or you will be soon,
these are some of the primary
workloads, EC2, RDS, S3.
We also have Aurora and for some reason,
I'm not remembering the last one,
but in any case, breadth and
depth, it's always growing
and as of last week, we actually
have a CEO to CEO agreement
to ensure that not only
will Cohesity customers
always get commitment to cyber resilience
and cloud resilience,
so will AWS customers.
So there will always be more when it comes
to how we can help you.
This is that architecture drawing
that I wanted to talk you through.
So on your left, there is a square
and so the left side of your screen there
really is kind of showing
how your on-prem data center
might look, maybe you're
using AWS Outpost,
which would be sitting on the edge,
might have an AWS storage gateway,
but you'll notice the
little data protect there
down the shield, down in
the bottom right of there.
We can help protect
all of those workloads.
Then if you go to the
right side of your screen,
I have a giant rectangle over there.
Those are your cloud workloads
that you might be looking
to protect if you're an Azure, excuse me,
if you're an AWS customer.
And so, and again, data protect.
Now, if you go to the middle,
you'll see a bunch of arrows.
You can protect your on-prem
workloads to the cloud,
cloud to on-prem, you can do replication.
That's that customer
choice that we talked about
a couple slides ago.
So we'll help you scale and protect
according to whatever
your enterprise needs.
Kevin talked a lot about cloud vaulting
as one of the methods that he is using
to ensure that he's following
that 3-2-1 backup rule,
for example.
Now, our cloud vaulting solution
offers quorum capabilities.
I'll show you this in
just a minute in my demo.
So you have the quorum capabilities.
So when you're looking
at segregation of duties
and ensuring that someone is in there
approving both sides of an
action, and it could be anything.
It could be recoveries.
It could be policy changes.
It could be as simple as not being able
to remove a backup or delete anything.
We also have the data
lock, which is the worm.
So you can't tamper with the information.
And we also use RBAC.
So it's very based on your role.
You may or may not be
able to make a change
or even see it for that matter,
just depending on your role.
When I think about that scenario
where I shared with you,
we had the automation tool,
the desktops imaging servers.
When I think about the recovery pathway
that we had to go to, I
hadn't shared this with you.
So we were able to get most
of our critical systems,
most back online within about 24 hours.
And unfortunately it did
affect critical systems.
And then beyond that though,
I mean, this recovery
process went on for weeks.
And so if we had a solution like this,
I think we would have been
able to get things back faster
because we know it's not tampered with.
We know there's no malicious malware
sitting in there, et cetera.
All right, so let me go ahead.
And I don't do live demos at the events.
I prerecorded one for you.
We don't play with the powers
that be that control demos,
but I'm gonna give you a
live voiceover of this demo.
I'll walk you through it.
So let's go ahead.
So this is our dashboard for
our cyber vaulting solution.
In terms of what I'm gonna look
at first are the cloud vaults.
So think data sovereignty,
think about all the regions
Kevin shared global.
You have the ability to
vault copies of your data
anywhere in the world
in terms of whatever
your requirements are.
Now we talked about quorum as well.
So separation of duties.
Separation of duties is a critical,
like your CISO cares
about separation of duties
for critical workloads.
And this isn't any different.
You don't want a malicious actor to get in
and be able to recover a
system or delete a backup.
And we get really granular
with what you can put
separation of duties on.
And it's done relatively simply.
So you just click in the upper
corner to get that started
because I already have one set up.
We're just gonna give it a quick edit.
So very simple UI to navigate.
And what I'm gonna show you next
is that you have the operations.
This is where you would choose
what you're creating
separation of duty on.
And then here's where you
set up your approvers.
So these could be, it could
be geographically dispersed.
It could be to help if
someone's on vacation,
you have a backup.
I have two approvers
of the three required.
Things will cancel out within four hours
if nobody's responded.
And this is the centralized location
that you can keep track of that.
So you can see I have a
wide variety of approvals
and even some declines.
Now, in terms of this,
this is a summary screen
that is showing you
that I have vaults
successfully occurring or not.
If I had a problem, it
would show up here as well.
This protection dashboard would
also show us our recoveries.
So in just a moment, I'll go
ahead and just start talking
a little bit more forward looking.
So how does a data
protection policy occur?
Protection job, you need a policy.
So I have a couple policies,
more than a couple,
and I have pre-set them up
and I could create a new one.
In just a second, you'll see
me point out in the upper right
how you could go ahead
and create a new one.
Now, in terms of what we're seeing here,
you're just seeing me click through
what it takes to add a vault.
So when you think back to
the beginning of the demo,
I showed you where all those
vaults were set up in advance.
That's where this is coming from.
I've chosen Oregon West.
Give this a second.
What we're gonna show you,
or what I'm gonna show
you in just a second here,
we're gonna edit.
If you look, I have another job.
When I think about 3-2-1 backup rule,
I can have multiple
vaults of the same data
across the globe.
I could even use different clouds.
So you have the ability, again,
it depends on the requirements
you need to follow.
If you did need to go with
a different cloud vendor,
you could.
All right, so now we're
initiating a recovery.
You've seen everything in just
a matter of a few minutes,
what goes into building this
and setting this up, right?
Pretty straightforward.
- Yes.
- I think that aligns
with your experience.
Now I'm gonna initiate a recovery.
So I'm going in, I'm choosing
actually a group of servers,
and I'm now selecting the vault copy.
So I'm gonna go ahead and initiate.
Now we've also talked
about some things today,
such as like air gapping
and going back to isolated environments.
This is an isolated environment
I'm gonna restore back to.
It's gonna give me the
ability to further analyze
the machine before I put
it back into production.
In theory, it's gonna be clean,
but it's always good to
have that peace of mind
where you can do the forensics.
Now, on the bottom, you'll notice
I add the prompt for quorum approval.
So what you're gonna see next
is I'm gonna go ahead and click.
So when you're logged in
as one of the approvers,
which was what the case was
here, it'll auto approve.
But then you also saw me go in
and do the other side of the approval.
And now we have a recovery
that has been initiated.
So pretty straightforward.
You need the cloud vault, you
need a data protection job
with a policy that's vaulting,
and you need to be backing
things up on whatever.
By the way, you can do
whichever recovery time
or recovery point that you need.
All right.
So I'm gonna just take a few
minutes to wrap things up.
So we talked about why shared
responsibility matters.
The biggest key takeaway for you today
is that your data,
regardless of where it lives,
is up to you to care for
and be able to recover.
We gave you a lot of really great tips
that you can bring
forward to your enterprise
for cyber resilience planning.
And look, Cohesity can help.
And in fact, we'd love for
you to stop by our booth.
We're at 1425.
I have some other resources for you
that you could also pull up and leverage.
But we'd love to see you.
We have some games.
Kevin, thank you for joining me today.
- Absolutely, thank you.
- And thanks to all of you for
joining us for this session.